[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wines cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Shh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh did that make you feel good
you should be ashamed
[Music]
[Music]
here this sounds about right to me
huh maybe we are live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning friends it's me Peter Brown
here with Rob handler II for our second
episode of Dino DNA today we're gonna
play rock 2 seeds of evil Rob you love
this game yeah we kind of had a little
not argument but a discussion on which
one would be better I think this is
better because there's more dinosaurs I
think you get into pretty quickly
yeah well the other one the original
Torah correct which has the title
dinosaur hunter yeah yeah Ecklie so
we're playing a PC version of this game
we've enabled a mess of cheats a mess of
just codes gonna mix stuff up I haven't
seen this since Nintendo 64 days yeah I
mean you're one to know to like argue
that like a TR TV is definitely ideal
for like older games so it's looks weird
when you're playing on like such a high
resolution like 1080p 60 yeah we'll do a
ten to sixty four overs yeah right so
this was
what they've mastered this not
remastered imported it or it is some
diversity yeah I love this game I've
been playing a lot of it well prove it
Rob here we go mmm yeah I played a
couple hours last night my stars
dinosaur surprise I know John you know I
mean I I feel it
I'd be lit if I hadn't had to be up on
this platform all day
I've been waiting a million years to you
I am a Don the elders of the lost land
known as the Lazarus Kong quarters have
charged me with the task of guiding
Marwan in quest to stop the primer Jim
oh yeah I lasted Sanders pleased to
destroy the five energy totems that keep
you imprisoned within the wreckage of
his life chief not a dinosaur
if he succeeds in destroying five energy
reduce he will be free it's a recent
wave of temporal energy analyst will
destroy your universe we must stop the
prime engine to work to take the energy
totals at all costs and there also be
given additional mission objectives as
you venture deeper into each of the
world which elastics so what what was
the extent of that story it's going to
be a big explosion it's been destroyed
that's port of idea the seeds of evil ah
this once peaceful coastal village has
been utterly destroyed by death look at
that under the provisions come on
[Music]
whoa cool cam doesn't like hammer words
the dinosaur eats out - Tom defendants
utterly evil and very dangerous so they
do the primer Jin's bidding the
dinosaurs have a more sinister and per
class know people keep you mission
objectives unless evil my buddy was
addicted to it other day kept singing
actually three districts are fools
yeah the gameplay just a little bit down
activate oh yeah what about it that was
an awesome cartoon in my 14 years and a
fun dinosaur that these kids having keep
like hidden away in their garage but
when they needed to go out they put him
on a skateboard and give him like a
backwards yeah
I love it I never into that one if you
show you a clip of it no I think so
actually
definitely this song probably see look I
was telling you about these deaths
they're so dramatic
I don't remember these props being so
aggressive they like look out of place
it's good to kill for children yeah same
to wait till you see their faces they
look scary but they're cute
thanks to rod just this game multiplayer
was kind of a big deal what's the story
with the PC version
I looked I'm sure there are you know dis
cords or means of like getting to actual
servers but I didn't see any like in the
game but oh hello these guys are the
worst doctor all this time well lucky
for us oh that's right oh shoot i tought
that i turn them on away well I got that
on where you see it guys that's weird
oh my god now ownest all just hidden
strong Oh My gods this thing oh my god
that's right I more than what it means
oh man I'm loving it
yes yes how much of this game is spent
indoors because the first one is
definitely I got outdoors yeah I already
want to kind of skip around the cerebral
bore we'll get there
[Laughter]
they're not human so it's funny
do I go here down oh my god that's light
Tarak you have it all Wow do that ladder
get it Ricky Oh flare gun
I remember that being crucial for
certain areas and it better be I don't
know else through that flashlight
distracted
I think there's there are some really
poorly lit areas that you just need it I
remember it being oh I think there are
like kind of arachnid aliens that yeah
you can like distracting with them maybe
nope skew something else mmm sound
effects oh yeah biggest rock dear
healthy
my kid first fire
I got unlocked the cage
[Music]
this had to have come out what was lost
world because it's so those those tiny
little uh Becky what a lost world
beginning of the world you bet oh I
didn't see your face shoot I wanna say
95 96 ok oh ok this backpack is saving
watch this foot rag dog so great oh man
these weapons all right where we going
here oh hell yeah
scope action
lobbies have alternate mmm-hmm the blood
so excessive hey guys yeah the
multiplayer was great you could a man
replied with my my siblings and I was as
most kids are weird
I would you feel like no I'm a raptor
and you can't use any weapons and I have
to kill you as a raptor took your place
for every fun oh yeah that's great yeah
I won't give you the satisfaction oh
here we go you guys very worst
I don't know this thing
Oh cerebral ball right there - hood ball
of lava
right
oh these are mine layer oh yeah these
will uh yeah that's right
no legs ha ha ha let us
oh here we go
area Raptors who said there were no
Raptors through these goofy guys
oh my god yes
that's right you locked out on it
oh that's that's aggressive projects you
know that Raptors favorite type of
sandwiches
I do now
I like it I like it
hold on dude one second
oh my god that's right and then they
explode right go on yeah
all right we should skip levels I want
to see everything this game has to offer
options right if you were a rafter
mm-hmm
[Music]
peanut butter Captain Crunch or oh did
that make you feel good Froot Loops Yee
cruel oops wrong answer damn it oh no
this is just makes this to be dark oh
wait [ __ ] yes it does
hence the flare let's see that in action
here where are you flare look at look
see look how great it works nope mmm no
sorry big hands and feet yeah thank you
let's get to a better level though first
yeah let's do that there we go - spooky
river of soul
slaughter by the river of souls with a
face the river so the river very name
strikes fear into the hearts of men I
mean the drinks of its water survives
the Lazarus Concordance erected one of
the energy totems on its banks and the
people of the lost land quickly learned
that it's mysterious energy could purify
the water of the river of souls on the
very shores of the deadly river a mighty
city sprang forth where once there was
but death life flourished oh the
dinosaur vanguard has swept through the
beautiful city of arrived in no good
campaign of terror rages on speaking of
no good Mike McCarty is once in your
favorite water - or a decades of peace
and prosperity so little need my heart
mr. Grint answer forces green uh your
mission objectives oh yeah Megalodon
destroy - so gates whoa legions that's
pretty cool okay gun playing through
these gates until I start about what the
hell is because door destroy all of the
solar gates before the end date can
escape yeah the other
he stole my guy babies up to say I
forgot all this during the guys like me
locate the end yeah I think so and yet
she's down
oh yeah oh yeah this one to ride that
thing
damn right whoa that way oh yeah look at
this
which way Peter left her ride ah right
oh hell yeah yeah just runs away yeah
you would sprint wait are you just
wrangling dinosaurs
Oh what oh I put them back in this cage
oh you I got really thank you I also
thank and run them over
oh that's sick company one chat asking
this is not the Nintendo 64 room there
was a port to PC
and it just kind of works no problem
yeah runs pretty well
what kind of turret are you there's guys
in there apparently big handy mode yeah
okay I do know you I know you want that
nope
tiny mode that could be fun bighead Oh
does that make you feel good
I got rambha Oh beautiful
hi thanks for doing the video we're
gonna have to do one more thing oh my
god wow wow this looks way better those
heads
oh there's Oh what the hell Hilary
Chavez saying that maybe some of these
buildings are destructive well yeah
generally I feel like with there's like
a barrel next to it Oh
getcha
I do a little - here turret
oh look at that jets so long I love it
what's next our most of the levels in
this game like very like sort of like
just like a lot of hallways environments
um they do open up and I know that much
there's a couple levels I had in mind
that like remind me of what's next year
yeah like kind of like tree forts and
yeah you're definitely doing a lot of
exploring and some of them you should
probably move around let's do it oh hey
you guys there you go
move on to another one I actually don't
remember liking this part that much
that was his oh hey
[Laughter]
Punk
let's smooth it around here yeah yeah
what else we got
um you do a boss fight I mean if we can
cope with them we go right to it or
should we move say that for last
no I can do a boss gauntlet at the end
okay okay
death marches that sounds like one
that's probably that jumpin I know I'm
pretty sure this one I'm thinking of
yep tight this one's good dang the death
marshes Raimondo does that make you feel
good the death marshes are home to the
mighty pearl in a primitive and brutal
race of eight black creatures not
dinosaurs the pearl in regards layered
squeaking insects and are deeply
resentful of the progress humankind has
made that's right he's got a minigun oh
my god the prime agent oh your name
Harlan into believing that he bought in
the lost land over to them once they
have helped free him little do the
purlins know that the primer gen intends
to wipe them out as soon as Tarak is no
longer a threat though they are
unpredictable and untrustworthy drone
the prime engine has armed the party
course alright what is the story
[Music]
goodness your mission objectives are as
follows kill this man you fine skin
drink the provision destroy three
ammunition storage facilities hey I'm
just curious to know like also I mean I
hate the energy totem and defend it at
all come out like it's had to be a 98
release what what I still have your sons
I can use the Triceratops weapons now
let's get right to it I want to turn off
pitch black how do I have that thing on
so we'll see Dark City is not on right
no yeah this is what this is supposed to
be a dark man
what's the 2spooky mode let's find out
you should be ashamed of yourself
shut up flight mode no watch iron DS off
while that distance that draw distance
damn
[Music]
is that it was it that like they pop out
no the hack of it was it like ghosts oh
oh is it maybe write this pop out are we
left big pants official mmm that's
wisely these guys look like here we go
Kwan's cheap you should be ashamed of
your fashion
yeah it's got like weird I don't know
ghastly impacts
I want that off sorry one more time
where are you
2spooky mode should be up yeah yeah it's
let's why do you see the guy's face on
those icons where those things you just
picked up had this dude's face on it it
must be 400 that's a great noise Oh for
water on a microphone what's in this
static I got last night
[Music]
oh you're right yeah yeah sure what a
great car you such a good code or leave
it on people are asking for the cerebral
bore Rob yeah I was holding back on it
cuz I feel like we got a long ways to go
but let's do it
cool a little sniper here where's my aim
it's a tranq gun oh my god that's right
dude I feel like I'm making contact
you're totally me
razmik tremors
this guy giving the old cerebral there's
our guy ready for it
Sherlock my gang a lock I think you try
different enemy I am Groot
where do you fall little baby hurt I
love it
well I think he was cute I liked where
there as I would have imagined if they
do at the end right they show teenage
group yeah like that
why you don't like me who died no your
girlfriend that was so funny massage yes
I don't know I feel like it's just hey
let's make a thing with big head big
eyes small body oh oh here we go
I guess he knows what's coming Wow yes
can you use another guy we will
definitely find out what's that you want
to lobotomy think you want syllabi over
here this is Blair Witch that you just
standing in the corner yeah where I
don't see you wait where are you oh my
god really
I'm sorry thank you bye ha ha I didn't
he just want to see if you could do it
okay you're cool god this path fight
yeah your cycle charted oh man I climb
ladders like this - lets get this going
again I don't think it works on these
guys try it why don't you try it I am if
there's no lock it won't fire in less
than walk yeah it's got a lock that's
fine - give me some of this
Oh see that all missed it what right
through go into his body
that looks great yes heads and has a
whole new dimension in there is oh this
is kind of funny like this
so these are like ways of getting health
and ammo but watch help watch how like
intuitive it is what do you want Peter
uh give ammo okay grunting what else you
want
I want health okay health granted okay I
think that's about it right yes okay
let's go back I guess ultimately its
means of like getting from like
different locations but like it's just
like yes give me it all right yeah mmm
there's no consequences of like - yeah
it's weird
- some of this she just really wants you
to ask yeah I think she's just oh yeah
absolutely
ultimately she's super bored
let's get some more cerebral oh we can't
rank them to shoot ah yeah go to sleep
whoa
oh that's cool mr. welding go to sleep
now the real question is will they wake
up if so no too soon are you bored yet I
[Laughter]
wish I had this who else we got
got blood on it
thing takes so long oh wait
[Laughter]
idiot okay weapons we miss you
let's go through this
I thought that gun does okay I got
energizer weapon
these dudes got away with murder gangsta
black skies oh that's great
I'm into it tight
[Music]
long distance oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah find him my my precious Oh
give me up here our missing it I'm
missing all the fun
[Laughter]
why is this not fit in perfectly I
that's a fair point
I remember this weapon was like to me
like controversial like I can't believe
they actually just connected like they
pushed the limits it's too much it's too
graphic actually move on a level here or
we could add some more codes oh hey I
mean what's the what's gonna make this
funny Oh does that make you feel good I
don't know if either be ashamed to great
point you should be ashamed of yourself
I mean ultimately I just want to see
everything in this game flight mode yeah
what the hell is flight mode let's fly
Oh does that make you feel good is cool
now this games good
oh my ha ha ha ha ha Wow
pre Slenderman where they're hard
they're hard is CS sure oh my god
soon another level what else we got here
ah let's see how many bosses are there
we can hit the bosses sorry three bosses
I guess there's only six levels said a
little I guess crazy I mean they're long
like you see a lot more stuff
let me there get really good Peter let's
go to layer the blind ones that sounds
cool wait didn't we do that one already
now mrs. death marshes I was thinking
your River of Souls huh stupid of de
leur of the blind ones I bet there's
some blind and meanest oh yes
legends tell of ghostly figures emerging
at night from underground and drag
against or it's though they do not
possess the power of sight the blind
ones are hardly hopeless they can hear
the beat of a heart and smell the blood
of an instrument at Mary's dog charity
and a lustful warmbier
the centuries deep beneath the surface
of the musty oh my god Blair you a
mission of death eight in a room just
layer them all there seal three thermal
vents trapping the blind ones beneath
tons of rock tons of rock the camera
work is pretty that's the energy total
bird and defend like a mobile critical
nice alright let's check out this oh
yeah I can fly cloud of my rifle
neighbor capability enable me break
[Laughter]
at some point we will turn on every
single one of these ooh here this looks
huh hello describe it
water
stone pillars okay besides the lag type
or a stalagmite
it's a stalactite
Gaiman cut it was like some trick to
remembering that what is it I'm not
quite sure I know you're talking about I
think I deleted all that from your brain
that's right you can do that yeah man oh
I just beat again that was the end of
the level great work
you failed a chat what is that what's a
little trick to remembering stalactite
or stalagmite it's very important
greetings to rock how may I assist you
[Music]
I'm some hot babe granted why is she
here - cuz she's different
mmm that's that's the rule
alright let's see what else got here uh
do we turn all of them on okay [ __ ] it
oh that's how you supposed to play this
game woah this is way better
oh man this is so cool oh look at this
I think he's underneath the floor where
are you no yes
[Laughter]
Wow
what I think he died
stalactites animal-type so they don't
fall oh the blood stays the same Rob's
not listening sorry I'm sad again for
you so as to lack tights is the one of
the ceilings it needs to hold on tight
oh that's pretty easy there you go
hey we learned something today we also
learned that this is a bad choice here
we go
got him
so I don't know about you I'm I think
people who think the earth is flat
they're kind of out of their minds but
there is one controversial topic that I
I think I pull on the other side of
reason if you will the right side of
reason okay let's hear it I don't think
dinosaurs are actually extinct yeah well
they're mean birds right
oh you think there's like a cave
underneath the planet where there's a
couple just like hanging out are you
being sorry being serious okay
keep a light okay okay probably what
millions of dinosaurs at one point
roamed the earth millions mm-hmm how is
someone gonna kill a million dinosaurs
by themselves I don't believe in meteor
so I don't want to hear that what you
you don't think a meteor hit and I'm
pretty sure that was proven I'm pretty
sure meteors don't exist Rob oh my god
Peter
look I'm just saying we could be playing
real-life tour rock dinosaur hunter
rather than this amazing game facsimile
I should hit those bosses let's go
another level they're called no they're
not man I honestly remember this game
being way better don't they say about
rose tinted glasses I should be ashamed
of yourself shut up all right
oh we just haven't gotten to a good
level yet hive of the mantids is that
the good one that's actually
the hive of the Mantid see look at these
guys
the mantids are an aggressive and
extremely intelligent race of insects
that have established a large colony in
the last land in recent years
just recently aren't capable of pity
remorse or is he my me he exists solely
to further their only goal to this end
the prime agent has persuaded the
mantids to help freehold was five years
to get the right new worlds to infest
he's on doing [ __ ] world on endless
look at that guy dance it's being ready
to transport an army of energy or well
destroying the master computer will your
mission objectives are as follows
Oh distress me Queen take this bugger
[Laughter]
destroy the master computer
that's a cool computer I wish I had that
underneath my desk and defend it at all
costs all right oh this is already cool
[ __ ] how cool this is
see that combo oh here we go oh look I
can use it on this turret get them
oh man that's a good joke that's a
pretty good show
Wow sir if you can live it turned on you
and it was like look I got oh this is
big head mode that's why they look so
dumb is that what
nope they just look dumb oh hey that
weapon is out of control
how are we going here
Oh No okay oh I'm home
what is
daddy's home
and you get yet yeah queer
Oh dance
guys like that know what this is printer
action here well I'm just going I threw
the sandy yeah we next you guys like
this oh you guys like this where is
everyone
I do not [ __ ] here we go here's the one
dude
patrolling now he looks oh look he likes
it can we dance whoa sick fight plasma
rifle why are we using cheats he enabled
we have to skate
I don't mean as a flight to your snow
it's fine yeah yeah I don't think the
tranq gun has any effect on these guys
oh we have not even done this one yet we
play like a really phenomenal game on
the show we should that's it but this is
pretty phenomenal right here I mean I
could just do this all day
oh oh what's up what's up oh now I got
it yeah this is it
oh these are upgrades oh whoa what was
that shield number one show off could
fly it's doing the tiller worm alright
next level cool
hi tree moving right along here we got I
say let's do boss fights let's just
briefly check out this we're just
warping through this stuff oh yeah this
is a cruel ones lightship why we're on a
spaceship and little it's got into
actual computers in danger most about
the light ship is the left Mantid
[ __ ] lethal biomechanical invaders
Oh grammar do their masters getting the
vessel itself is massive oh that's from
what American sound right no I just mean
I don't think it's her but I'm very
super that he's like this is like Oh to
the Nerds young giant spaceship I'm
talking to the separatists can only find
orchids deep within the Super's right
the indoor kids yeah in the event that
the primer gene is defeated the biobots
have been programmed to work
with the light ship what Raticate dory
from the firebot that's a pretty cool
name they had me take as much pride you
know
at one point people got an argument
that's committed like apologize to each
other the next day because they weren't
so beholden to their ideas because
doesn't really matter they hugged they
up they had a drink together some guy
was like yes
the biobots waist created by the light
ship's power cells is whoo yes you did
it a good place in the river of souls I
couldn't have done it without you guys
the toxins will be eradicated and the
rewards always that famous Pat özil bit
words about the unheard inside it's
clean the death bed the bed that eats
people
it talks about the guy who wrote it and
there's like one of two ways either was
every morning just wake up the pillows
suffocate yeah this is awesome or he
says would be worse it is as if he had
like writer's block sand he fought
through them like what am i doing no I
will finish this whoa these guys are
neat
dude someone who has to write for a
living there really is the whole works
- leave a deadline oh yeah
that's cool
daddy's home I love this room this is a
brings back memories are you to be
around today I wanna have a speedrun
this
what the hell are you
it's like bb8 inspiration
what's this I think it's a shelf
you
guys has got under control man I think
we I didn't made a mistake on that plane
is on six support ago I think that's why
it doesn't look a fool what do you think
I mean the frame rate is so high the
textures are so crisp that it's just
like it loses that that stench that way
yes this was a game that was played
under certain constraints cuz this is
[ __ ] high res low quality [ __ ] right
oh wait well you know we should have
done maybe it's just played it at like
480 resolution is that gonna screw up
wood huh no I totally would give a shot
you sure I don't know we could always
fix it
Hays gonna bust in here I don't care
come at me J it's the lowest resolution
week of dad's gonna come in and get
really mad you know he likes to be
called daddy J I know he sends me
reminders every day I changed it to
sixty Hertz no there you go
and yeah and her baby uh requires a
restart uh boo boo that's dumb next time
next time this is fine though oh I turn
down the resolution scale so that looks
a little better oh okay that actually
helps like this needs to be a little
blurry
yeah right that's actually interesting
it really does
hero Enya biggest blare oh I always go
for it yeah I was gonna steam engine up
it's the early phase of Duke steam punk
man I hit every era Oz arena shot I'll
do this one second yeah yeah yeah
anything for you
oh man hey imagine an arrow just in your
butt right through ya come on talk about
a horrible way to sell a week [ __ ] about
a hole in would talk about a hole in one
is a door what are you what how does it
do what you didn't destroy the assembly
Clint's [ __ ] man alright let's get
to the meat oh man Liz James and the
YouTube chat says Tay prefers T Diddy
have we ever called him T Diddy no will
we forever on call him T Diddy I will
puff Diddy
that sounds real rap I could do that
good but we can warp to the credits oh
man alright Peter we got four bosses
here let's start with number one work
our way should we actually try to beat
them like with no cheats
yes except bighead no I want to see all
right well depending on I mean I will
kill them because I'm super good this
game so
oh are you Oh gross those burritos one
[Music]
is this the boss oh no it was the
beginning of something else
Oh turtle head this guy's needs a ticket
oh oh oh oh my god oh I got better
weapons right I feel like I'm really
good myself
yeah you are
there any way I can you know it's any
skill here for dodging this gun is so
insane fire one and I fire all three
hits like hmm oh great
I got idea Noel sound Oh who left the
trash out
Oh good point that's kind of deep yeah
oh this is one this you should try this
Oh
next up rectum fight rekt oh damn near
killed where at the time time it rights
are those right into the sphincter
uh no I'm smoking gum I got mad at my
girlfriend any day she does this thing
where instead of saying like she'll say
reckless all your fights have been so
unnecessary she's talking about taking
one of our pet food temperature I'm just
saying
putting the thermometer
- thermometers reckon
yeah Goodman tankiness yeah cuz gayness
is fun
this is a sick-ass boss fight oh look at
this game sucks broken oh my god no no
this is it this is the best one for
these guys
whoa sorry I was loud
Oh
Oh Oh stop all right that's it all of
those guys in a sec yeah where's the
audio here use the music sucky note did
nothing
my god listen life is now it's getting
good
now I shoot it why I've into it sigh I
turned it off stakes for me mission
failed was amazing look at all those
exclamation points I know there's no way
this was in the game they had with added
that like because it the game uh is just
so difficult to like in tedious right
you're just backtracking the whole time
like what the hell
[Laughter]
oh is this cuz I don't have the keys I
think that's it
wait I want you to fly I want you to see
how far away you can fly okay just shoot
for the moon does that make you feel
good mhm yes geri halliwell it does not
masking visible walls here oh what a
bust
okay so oh here we go
all right all right I can do that
keys keys keys keys keys beautiful does
that make you feel good put all these
keys in open all these doors
what what's up
who does he look like to you I wanted a
tie root is a way better answer than I
was a James Franco maybe but tie root is
that's deaf all man he should have been
at following
so awesome oh I just automatically warp
to the next posture
Oh didn't catch that
like keeps us green on the outside smart
smart
all right Butthead
oh I remember this fight here I do
oh he's just on the comp here let me
send in my minions
yes ls1 yeah well all fine
those look like their nuclear balls
one lie - do you hear I think you have
to wait for
ah there you go those things oh wow
those ghosts Interpol cool
oh not many dinosaurs this man's coming
out we've seen to that is no three
who's this guy remind you of Mike my
Hardy that's good call
doesn't feel like Mike might have Mike
has that one tentacle on the right left
arm ins was like scythe arm oh look he
loves it he makes me happy yeah favorite
dance moves so he prays to God wow wow
wow wow wow what is this oh that was a
health regen there damn that's a cool
way to do it now that hurt I like his
wings
I like his breath shootin
uh-oh uh-oh daddy found a glitch
why isn't he losing me help my supposed
to shoot something else
maybe he's weak to love I mean you think
the brain hits would be doing something
running out of these
no I don't want you know we can't afford
yeah
I think the brain is a weak spot here
see see this if you're gonna cerebral
for anyone
oh [ __ ] gotta be this oh my God thank
you God
come on hole lock no Oh No
brain damage image image image image
image [ __ ] oh my god this is so good
why why would I do that maybe you don't
get it yet in this part of the game
maybe you don't
[Music]
from like this angle does this look like
it goes down further guys cuz I can
trippy
kidnap design see I really don't want to
die yard so I'll use my phone out there
though oh how is he not dead I don't
know I don't know
I don't know you're sane oh my god
you're so good damn it
we men killed with kindness to the face
how does he have red blood all his
buddies have maybe like a humanoid type
thing
alright that's it all right
no way
stay there
all right I'm calling you look this
possible let's do this oh you should be
ashamed of yourself
I got Roomba mm-hmm you should be
ashamed
[Music]
oh my god god damn it we have to see him
die what are we doing on here anyone the
chat know how to take down this hunk of
waiting
well
am I missing here it's a pewter
is calm
oh there you guys
you
ah
no dude just died
he's pissed
yeah come back out yeah Peter hang in
there how is this health bar even I like
working
oh my god
[Music]
what is this this is a new one
[Music]
no this is the best boss ever all right
really
we have to kill it this is cool
now again somewhere oh this is your
computer straight full you got nothing
you're doing nothing
thank you I'm sorry I just wanted to see
him die queen boss
I like how they make the distinction
between their being a queen boss and a
mother boss oh yeah good boy oh this
looks like genitals oh pretty boys good
let's get some real action see here how
come their lives oh okay uh-huh there we
go now we're talking nope they don't
have brains
were you at doesn't work on you oh my
god it's the best weapon
let's think here that's not doing
anything here so let's do let's do this
or yes
it has this field
blowing up your [ __ ] I know I guess it
wants me to hit it it's for mid-arm
really
apparently really get in here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh you see this this one opened up hmm
waving yo ass
he's a cheat no enter not oh my god I
want to get out on the ground here Peter
yes ooh there goes hi bud oh yeah giant
lice alright let's give them some this
[Music]
how far is it yeah
[Music]
yeah it is
oh you got no arm oh here we go nice
work
Oh how would you rate that last boss
fight [ __ ] it's good score whoo well I
guess I gotta turn on this god damn code
and order yeah yeah I'm ashamed of this
game right now and actually I'm ashamed
myself I should have picked a better
game I thought this was gonna be fun I
don't blame you I blame the gamers this
was like an all-time favorite growing up
how many years ago was that two years
two years going new you were a big all
right do you remember know what these
bosses work well with these glasses now
this boss is dead all right
oh oh oh no wait we did the Queen boss
right duh probably let's do Mozza boss
what was the Queen boss that alien no no
no no Jesus Christ it has found a better
arm right legs did someone order a
gymnast
this I can get behind so far yes oh wow
[Music]
so under Wow well they always have to do
this
Horrible Bosses on well that's kind of
cold today more continuing this is
basically non loss
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you don't have one okay mm ears don't
you dare pull out your phone let's try
this again I don't have flight mode on
how'd that happen huh or you know swish
I wonder why this is called mother he
almost wants to say Chicago seal the
seals are we go crab fishing he's just
pissed that he got his hand stuck in it
you guys hands stuck in an escalator
oh oh oh boy all right
know what it means yeah we're gonna need
that on in order to not break this game
despite I mean wow this pose he looks
like dare gee that does it go on that's
it burn mad Oh those ads
you've hit his arms do you call these
arms what is this game
oh you think you're pissed now
sucky
what happened to music is there really
no music it's the least of our worries
that's why maybe that's why we're not
having a good time maybe you change the
soundtrack soundtrack version oh maybe
that's why I want CD that's probably yet
Oh change the voice language ooh
Deutsch damn boss it's good he's just a
German developer it is now that sounds a
little jerk
Oh miss
there's the music this is way better
it's better
you know
Oh his tentacles are coming oh now I get
the vibe he has those
yeah
Oh Oh
we sing
yeah
hmm
because I looked weird don't you think
what's the only thing about
oh he's got a couple of laps there
although this is mother she ran are them
yeah we're using mouse and keyboard yeah
maybe that's why we should play for the
controller
get ready for that health bar to
recharge why did you speak at one did he
flip me off and he just looked at his
arms like
he looks very calm what's going on
what
that's a huge middle finger
what was that
why did he run back is it now he moves
oh wow that's pretty cool
like that Oh Oh No
but like I know I know but no I mean I'm
just I'm wondering like what is I don't
know I was trying to think of us the
standard right like what did like
ocarina time 1988 so around this time
right
well again man and there's Sharad better
release title
like a year maybe after or what yeah the
least a year
Oh
Oh
Oh Oh what's gonna have his bus smelling
his armpits yeah
alien oh I'm just helping him out
now you go for the head
my weapons here
come back to me blade how do you catch
that
where
no action
that
yeah
I really don't know what to say
just a bowl
all right let's you grow back ahead
Oh
strop - and I'm pretty sure
Oh
like I bet you can't do this later you
see my toes still oh sure do love video
games Rob what what oh look it's the
Triforce didn't that's where the where
the lore crosses over are you sure this
is Tara I thought it was so if you're
surprised as I am yes we are cheating no
Alvarez yes we are cheating
all right well I'm happy that uh we were
able to fill the time or worried who
knows all we want to do is just fill
time um no I really really enjoy
streaming we do stuff but um hey wait
it's a journey man it's a journey and
we're sorting things out no no no is
this the last boss I don't know but
we're not doing it did I accidentally
pick this guy I don't know queen boss
was the okay
click fruity stripes for sure whatever
you do I'll towards the top yeah you
should be ashamed of yourself
oh now it's kissable No
but don't you want to see the ending of
the game
didn't he beat this guy no we cancelled
we bounced out
I'm confused we accidentally pick him
must've yeah had to that's my boss was
the you want primogenitor I mean that
would be the last one this is what I
picked is clean boss was the UH
the fog with the butt right and this guy
sucked yeah okay let's see what the
credit show us maybe that maybe this is
a good part of the game okay just go
Jones oh my god look at the background
there I am look at that squat oh my God
look at that that's an actual galaxy so
they look like what is even a
transparency look at that
is that because we've did we get to
blame who'd we get to blame for this
[ __ ] okay Stephen kick I guess
Preston flood is a cool name it is
additional arts pen only two dudes
tested this game damn the two dudes who
did the multiplayer level design were
also the testers oh I was hoping that
was the only credit sequence here we go
here we go here's the meet no no what we
really want to know too is who wrote
this that's true
oh man I wonder if you're going to have
that in here art art art
art more art tray tray Zaman Zeeman
please do who wrote this who wrote this
masterpiece uh additional design by the
entire to rock to team what the [ __ ]
kind of credit is that Jason carpenter
voice talent here we go there's no name
oh okay
turn its head Mason he had a voice
oh yeah the last guy Oh Oh double is
additional voices ROM it's Tubbington
that is a [ __ ] name dude holy God Wow
dude there's no way that's got to be a
joke don't joke about names like that
Gromit stubbington1 Aaron stuff Wow
yeah Wow Nigel cook there were no
writing credits by the way there were
none like
all right well I think that's gonna do
it let's do it we're gonna do it ah what
am I going to hear which 20 want me to
click on the one that says outro no no
don't do that go back no you uh do uh
just camera just camera about to be live
must be live guys well success yeah you
know
no no winners uh
what I'm gonna play next week maybe a
more modern yeah there couple other
dinosaur ones is the one Callie was
telling us about
carnivore - yeah no dinosaur ha Master
Hunter was it would you say was a
carnivore it was carnivore - something
something
will pick a winner yeah we'll pick a
winner uh Liz James and the chat says uh
like a co-op that's possible I'm sure
there's a dinosaur cooperated one look
into it but yeah uh we'll definitely
have something good for next week
absolutely this was fun though
I had fun this was fun I had a bad about
yes yes again thank you guys so much if
you have any recommendations for any
kind of dancer game puttin them
YouTube comments on Twitter
yeah I'm at Robert handler el1 101 Brown
PC brands B thanks for watching guys
it's been Dino DNA we will see you next
week at 11:00 a.m. Pacific specifically
on case huh what do you see
Dino DNA all right all right later y'all
later guys
[Music]
[Music]